is there advice you can give to young
folks how to be non-standard
how to stand out novelty how to generate
novelty that's what i want on my
tombstone i have one um
he he generated novelty no no how to
it's like how to
how still um
i just love doing science and so
when i was younger i was just just
wanted i mean i'm still not sure i'm a
real scientist right so i want to try so
my advice for the young people is just
if you just if you love asking questions
then don't be afraid to ask the question
even if it pisses people off because if
you piss people off you're probably
asking the right question what i would
say though is don't do what i did which
is just piss everyone off
try and work out how to
you know i think
if you're if other people are challenged
by your questions
you will get not only your respect but
people will give you create space for
you because you're doing something
really new
i really try to create space in my
academic career my my team
really try and praise them and push them
to do new things so my advice is
try to do new things get feedback
and the universe will help you
[Laughter]
because the universe likes novelty i
think so i think so right if this one
will keep them around
what about you sarah um you two like to
ask the really
out there
yeah
uh because i have a strong passion for
them so i think um
uh it goes back to the love like if you
if you're doing the thing you're
supposed to be doing you should really
love it um so i always tell people that
they should do the thing they're most
passionate about but i think a flip side
of that is
that's when you become uh in some mind
like not to sound cheesy but like your
best version of yourself so i guess like
for me as i become more successful in my
career i feel like i can be more myself
as an individual and so there's this
i've always been following the questions
i'm most interested in which very early
on i was discouraged from knowing by
many people because they thought they
were unanswerable questions and i always
just thought well if no one's even
trying to answer them of course they're
going to be unanswerable and then that
was kind of an odd viewpoint but the
more i i found my way in that space the
more i also made a space for myself
as a person because you're basically
generating the niche that you want to
exist in
um and so i think um
i think that's
that's part of it is not just to follow
your passion but also think about like
who do you want to be
and create that
you